on the hill the rockies ace their bon
marcus to a two
with a 208 era and closing in on a five
to one strikeout to walk ratio this ball
hit hard out into right field nobody
home out there it'll be extra bases for
chew blackman just now getting to the
ball and chew
eases into second base with a lead off
double
against the newest texas ranger the
longtime twin kyle gibson signed a
three-year free agent deal
in the offseason to join the rangers
he's a a sinker slider type of guy heavy
ground balls when he's
on his game and this ball is lined to
right it's misjudged by gallow over his
head trevor can fly he's around second
heading to third
and
he is safe
[Applause]
and that is sharply hit past o'dore
kemp's going to stop at second
two on and two outs for tony walters
and that's down the left line fair ball
matt kemp will roll home trail runner
mcmahon is going to get a green light
from stu coyle he's got to pick it up
throw to the plate he's not gonna get
him
tony walters coming through
you asked for a two-out hit he delivered
two-nothing rockies
get into a spot like this and you get
this kind of right-hander to face your
first start back this one down toward
that right field corner and that's a
fair ball
trevino
has a one-out double in the third
like i said really difficult can't
expect a lot and all jose does is shoot
a ball to right field with a little bit
authority
this ball hit out into right field
that's a base hit trevino around third
blackman
throw it right back towards second base
rbi single by two and the rangers get
one of the runs back
connor fluffa swings and punches one
through the right side past the dive of
murphy at base eight
chu hits the bag at second he stops
there
and this ball is loud to deep right
gallow back there again can't catch this
one he gets knocked around he needs help
from the center fielder
solac
which prevented that from being a second
triple for story
oh two and this one out to right field
drops in base hit
back-to-back singles
to start the fifth inning
a little offense here wouldn't hurt
there's the opportunity out in front of
chew at the moment and this one in the
air short center field that's trouble
drops in base hit andrews hustling
around third he'll score to tie the game
and we're even at two
and this one caught at third by arenado
back to first and that one gets away the
rangers will get the go-ahead run
to second base kinder philippa but
trevino allowed to score
when that one got away from
murphy he's in a lot of unusual plays
tonight
this ball hit on the ground sharply
arnado from the kneel on throw and it's
not in time solac will have an infield
hit i think it was in time i think
daniel murphy just couldn't hold on to
it with the ejecto mitt he almost shot
this ball back to the mound
in the air out toward right center field
that one will drop in base hit
to third base solo
he did because it hit hard enough for
two on the tag throw the first double
play
nolan coming through
[Applause]
i don't think he can turn it five four
three wasn't hit that hard wonderful
play by arenado again
there's a hard ground ball up the middle
and calhoun is on with a base hit
rangers have
racked up the base runners tonight
there's a base hit for gallow
heinemann stops at second first two men
on in the eighth inning
so now two gone it'll be up to dietrich
high in the air out to left field
tapia's back gone
dietrich with a three-run homer in the
eighth and he has done it again
huge insurance runs for the rangers they
lead six to two
left center field long run for solac and
he didn't make the play
and it kicked around out there charlie's
gonna end up in third
bad route to this ball but charlie will
take it
first triple this year for chuck nasty
so charlie at third nolan at the plate
he's over three and this ball's in the
air to gallow this will get charlie home
[Applause]
yeah you know he could throw but i
thought still there's no way
that was a 300 plus foot throw right on
the money he got behind that ball and
had momentum going home short arm throw
but look at the carry just at one hop oh
charlie's in there
2-2
got him swinging
story strikes out this one is over and
montero is five for five
in saves derek dietrich the hero again
and the rangers win it six to four